From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass.
When Shirin Jaafari moved to the US as a young adult, there were a lot of promises made to her family back home. We'll be in touch all the time, call you every week, almost like we're in the same town, which is the kind of thing you say. But Shirin actually pulled this off for the last 20 years.
We are a close family. We message several times a day. We send each other reels, like, normal stuff. I mean, I don't want to lose those details, those small details of their lives, because I am so far away from them.
And they really get into the details, this family-- who ate what, how far was the walk, what's the latest with the dental work? On the phone, by text, random thoughts tossed out at any hour-- have you seen this pumpkin dessert? Unsolicited suggestions.
I would send them videos of exercises they can do at home.
Like you worrying about them getting enough movement?
I would love them to-- yes, I have been trying to get my mom to do more yoga and my dad to not sit all day.
How's that going?
Not great.
So just like a constant, ongoing conversation with them.
Totally, the kind of thing that you would be asking them if you were actually in the same space and close.
Then in February, the United States and Israel attacked Iran, where her parents live. And on that very same day, the first day of the war, the Iranian authorities shut the internet down, just put the whole country into an internet blackout, a shockingly effective blackout.
The call wouldn't go through. It would just disconnect. I didn't hear anything. It would just disconnect.
Did you do it over and over again?
Yes, of course. I tried so many times. I wouldn't be able to get through. Calling through cell phone was impossible. It just became useless. The cell phone became useless for us. The only way I was able to communicate with them was them calling on a landline to my cell phone. That was the only way they could reach me.
Text message, email-- nothing else was working?
After that point, no. They called me on the landline. And it's funny when I think of it-- there were so many times when I visit them and I would tell them, who needs a landline? Maybe you guys should get rid of this. In this day and age, who needs a landline?
Inside Iran, what was happening was, as soon as the war started, cell phones were only working to call people inside the country, no internet. Communication with the outside world became so difficult, it was like going from breathing regularly out in the open to being underwater and breathing through a straw. Workarounds like VPNs are expensive or janky. Some are flat-out scams. And they're banned. A private satellite service like Starlink? Illegal. And people have been arrested for using it.
So the landline-- that was the only way Shirin's parents could reach her. But when bombing got too intense in Tehran, they fled the city, leaving behind the landline. And Shirin was left going for days, sometimes weeks, without hearing from them. Were they OK? Were they safe? She'd go on social media, scouring every platform, looking for anyone she knew in Iran who had found some brief internet workaround to ask them if they'd heard from her parents.
So sometimes I would stay up at like, 3:00 or 4:00 AM, looking for any information that I can get from any relative or friend or somebody who knows my parents that could be online. I would just send messages to everybody, like, hey, let me know if you are online. Let me know the next time you're connected. Can you give me an update? Just message me as soon as you see this message.
I've heard a lot in the last two months during this war about deals and negotiations. I've heard about bombings by the US and Israel, and by Iran. Also lots about oil prices and the stock market, and the Strait of Hormuz. But I haven't heard much at all from Iranians inside Iran. What are they seeing, and thinking, and doing, and talking about?
For the last few weeks, we've been working with two journalists in the United States, Fatemeh Jamalpour and Roxana Saberi, to collect voice memos from inside Iran. So many people sent messages, even though it was difficult and dangerous for them to get these messages out. But people wanted to be heard. I have not heard anything like these from inside Iran. I guess that's part of the point of an internet blackout.
So that's what I want to share with you. Today's show, we hear from people inside Iran, where war is only part of what's going on for them. That's coming up. Stay with us.
It's This American Life. Today's episode, Blackout. Other places have had their internet cut off during a war. Iran is not the first. But this isn't something that's being imposed on the country from the outside. It's being done by the leadership of the country to its own citizens while they're being attacked-- in this case by us, the United States, and Israel.
Listening to these messages that people sent us, you really get the feeling for how total a blackout is. I had the thought, listening over and over, that every part of what they're saying is not supposed to be heard, even basic things like, what are people doing every day? A blackout is not a censorship that goes line by line. It is wholesale redaction of people's lives, and sometimes deaths.
Here's what it took for people to get these messages out of Iran. They had to borrow or pay for a VPN or satellite connection, wait for it to actually work. Starlink connections in Iran keep getting shut down. They had to not get caught. Iranians have been imprisoned for speaking with foreign media. It sometimes took days to get these voice memos out of the country to us, often short messages, a minute at a time so the files were small enough to get through.
The messages came from a whole range of people, from different parts of Iran, different ages, professions, political views, and also different experiences. Every time I got one of these messages, I stopped what I was doing to listen all the way through. So I want to play them for you the way I heard them, one person after another. We have edited them but tried to leave them at a length where you can really hear what people have to say as they go about their day. I'm going to play the messages in four sections. We could call them acts.
So here we go, Act One, Both/And. In these first few messages, people talk about the dual experience of living both in a war and at the same time in an internet blackout, both dragging on and on, 63 days and counting as I record this now. First voice memo, Negin. She's in her early 40s and lives in Tehran with her boyfriend, Ameen.
After breakfast, I got ready to go to work, got into my car, and drove onto the highway. Then suddenly, Ameen called and said, Negin, they're bombing Tehran. That was pretty much my last call. All internet lines were suddenly cut off.
This message and all the messages you're going to hear in the show is being read by an actor. To protect everyone's identity in this show, we've changed people's names, and we've asked Iranian and Iranian American actors outside of Iran to listen to the messages and then record what people said and how they said it onto their phones as voice memos. Some of the original messages were recorded in English. Most were translated from Persian. Once or twice, we've changed a small phrase for clarity. OK, back to Negin.
And then they started hitting the East of Tehran, these strange, terrifying sounds. We were really not prepared for suddenly being in the middle of the highway and hearing sounds like that. Some people, they just parked their cars and they got out. And they were staring at the smoke. They didn't know what to do. Two, three people had gone and hidden in the bushes. It-- it was really strange.
Then this delivery guy on a motorcycle passed by me. He had this Kurdish accent. My window was down, and I was completely terrified. He passed my car and said, Bibi finally came. And I was like, my god, nobody even knows how this war is going to end. Who cares about Bibi?
I finally made it to Sohrevardi Street to go towards my mom's place. And I saw that they had closed all the schools, and they had called all the families to come pick up their children. Some of the mothers were clearly regular office workers. They were wearing their uniform of manteaus and trousers. And they were running on foot towards the schools because the streets were blocked. And everyone at the school was crying, begging for their children to come out faster.
And I went a little farther, and I got to this girls' high school. And I saw these girls come out. And they took off their headscarves and messed up their hair into the air. And they were chanting that, yes, now we are finally becoming free. [SLIGHT CHUCKLE]
Then a bomb hit somewhere nearby, and the sound was unbelievable. And at once, people just poured into the streets. And some people, clearly, they were gathering their things to leave Tehran.
Hello. Hope you're doing well. First, I apologize because, unfortunately, I've caught a cold these days. My voice is hoarse.
This is Pooya. He's in his mid-30s. He owns a pizza shop in Tehran.
But look, cutting the internet is a disaster. Our phones are constantly ringing. So-and-so, be careful. Such-and-such a place is being bombed. We worry about each other.
We wake up, try to have a normal day, which is not very normal. And we come to work, wait, reading the news. Some of us have the internet. Some don't. So part of the news is actually passed from person to person.
When Tehran is attacked, I don't do anything special. I just sit where I am and go about my day, truthfully. There have been many times when I was cooking or doing whatever, and I just continued doing it because there was nothing I could do at that moment.
People come out now, eat, go to cafes. But economically, you can't just say conditions are bad. Conditions are almost on the verge of collapse. We've laid off nearly 70% of the staff or almost more. People still come to buy pizza, but much less often. Regarding the menu, some things have been limited, for example, the salads or the appetizers, like chicken and so on because it might not be economically viable for people to buy them right now. I took away the salads for a month. I'm bringing them back at the end of this week. But our beef bacon pizza is among the best sellers.
There are checkpoints everywhere in the streets. The atmosphere is really unsafe, very highly securitized. And I mean, we're very afraid of these checkpoints. We're really as afraid of the checkpoints as we are of bombs and missiles.
Sarah is in her early 30s. She's talking here about checkpoints that have been set up all around the country by Iranian security forces, including the IRGC, the Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps.
We know they check phones. We know they search photo galleries. We know they've arrested people we knew because of just something they found on their phone, like a photo or a call, or following a certain page or something like that. It's very terrifying. For a long time, I just didn't take my phone out with me at all. But for example, now that I've started taking it out, I just constantly erase everything and clear my phone of everything.
Honestly, when things are outside of my control, I just start cleaning and tidying my house. I constantly clean everywhere in the house. I vacuum. I wash the dishes so the house is perfectly tidy. I cook. I start dusting, vacuuming, washing the bathroom, washing the kitchen, washing all the dishes in the sink. I started making jam, which I have never done before. I scrubbed the whole house with the thought that if there's no electricity or water, at least my house would stay clean for a few more days.
And then I took a shower. I blow-dried my hair. I mean, I know it's really stupid. Like, if they bomb your country's infrastructure, this might help you for, what, maybe two extra days? But it gave me a good feeling psychologically at least.
Next voice memo is from an emergency nurse, Silphia, in her late 20s. She lives in Isfahan, central Iran. Silphia talked about something other people mentioned too, trying to use the sort of substitute, very limited internal internet the Iranian authorities have created.
The national intranet only works inside Iran. It's its own system, tightly controlled and surveilled. There are apps for messaging, texting inside the country, banking services. There's an Iranian search engine called Torob. And sometimes some international sites can be accessed through the internal intranet, but others can't. Silphia had a day off work and was testing out what she could and could not do on the internal system.
I wanted to buy cologne, so I ordered that online. And I had no problem with the payment. Some sites that you used to connect to directly through Torob, they don't open now. And so I don't know why some open, some don't. I don't know what the problem is or what difference there is.
Now I almost feel a bit illiterate because before, whenever something came to my mind that I didn't know, I would quickly google it. And I spent so much time every day talking to ChatGPT. I would consult it about everything I wanted to do. But now I can't do any of those things because basically, my phone has just turned into a tool for calling, texting, taking photos, things like that. That's it.
There is an app they've provided as a replacement for Google called Zarebin, but I haven't been able to get anything decent out of it so far. What you search for has to be very common and simple, like searching for the name of a medicine, for example. And even then, it doesn't show all the references. It brings up some very simple Iranian references and basic explanation. Otherwise, it doesn't give you a proper answer for anything else. I even wanted to find a number for a fast food place through it so I could call them, but it wouldn't bring it up for me. That's how ridiculous it is.
Okay, now I want to play a different group of messages for you. Act Two, The Blackout Before This One. From an American perspective, we went to war with Iran. That's what's happening there. That's where the story begins. But this war for Iranians landed in the middle of an ongoing story about what's been happening inside the country. And these next two people who sent voice memos, they had a role in that story.
There have been regular large protests against the Iranian regime for years in Iran. And right before the war, massive demonstrations erupted around the entire country. People took to the streets demanding the end of the regime, which has been in power in Iran for almost 50 years. The protests went on for weeks. And then Iranian authorities put the country into a full communications blackout. It started on January 8. Over the next few days, during the blackout, security forces massacred people all across the country. They killed thousands, possibly tens of thousands, of their own citizens.
They did this at a moment when there was no way for people to tell anyone, to post photos or videos, or to warn their friends, or call international reporters, or even reach family outside of the country. We still don't know the scale of the killing. Human rights groups have been trying to document as many deaths as they can. In a blackout, you can die without being counted.
The two reporters who collected voice memos for today's show, Roxana Saberi and Fatemeh Jamalpour, also managed to get messages out during the last blackout. Dozens of people inside Iran found ways to send them rare firsthand accounts-- images, videos, medical records-- that suggested that the IRGC and other security forces shot protesters at close range, targeting their heads and chests, their eyes.
The protests and killings in January haunted some of the voice memos we got, even as people try to continue living, going about their normal routines. Amin is in his 20s. He's a professional bodybuilder in Tehran. He joined the protests. One of his friends was shot and killed while protesting, Mehdi Zatparvar. He was a well-known champion bodybuilder.
I've been on a special diet since January. I wanted to compete back then, but I didn't. I canceled it out of respect for those who were killed, out of respect for Mr. Zatparvar. After that, competitions were canceled altogether. And gradually, I just kept my diet because I saw I had nothing else to do.
I usually wake up at 4:45, and I do my cardio from 5:00 to 6:00. I get by with seven or eight meals a day, even though prices have skyrocketed and my savings are completely gone, but I am still keeping at it anyway.
I generally don't follow the news anymore, neither Iranian nor foreign news. Iran International says one thing, and Iran state TV says another. So I simply don't get my mind involved with the news anymore. Unless, for example, Trump tweets. Whatever he posts, we basically assume the opposite because he either does exactly what he says or the exact opposite.
Right in front of me is a checkpoint, and I am passing through it. The IRGC is completely controlling everything with its own full supervision. Recently, I've been recording videos as motivation for those who think they just need to sit at home during the war. I really want to try to convince them, through exercise, they can live in a way that at least keeps their vibes high.
Anushirvan is a doctor in the north of Iran. He's young, in his mid 20s. He spent January treating hundreds of wounded protesters, some of them shot with military-grade weapons, sometimes at close distance, sometimes in the head. And while he was treating people, plainclothes security agents roamed the hospital. So if someone needed an X-ray, Anushirvan and his colleagues would personally escort them to radiology so they wouldn't be detained. They showed people how to leave out the back door of the hospital.
As he worked, Anushirvan began saving X-rays and photographs and notes in a panic that the regime, through its blackout, would succeed in hiding what it had done. In a lot of ways, it has. And now, in another blackout, an endless blackout, Anushirvan is just still doing his job, getting through each day.
After eating a very sad excuse for a breakfast, I fed my cats, which I had adopted after the events of January due to my friend's recommendation to have a companion in those times. I believe it helped. Very interesting creatures, cats are. I dressed up and called for, you could say, an Iranian version of an Uber to the hospital, went downstairs.
And looking at the car, it was barely functioning and being held together. And the driver had a very, say, stereotypical type of beard. And my suspicions were confirmed when I sat in the car and saw two stickers of Soleimani and Khamenei on the dashboard of his car, not exactly the two faces I want to see that early in the day, but you know.
So he drove me to the hospital and saw a white lab coat in my bag and asked if I was a doctor. And then he said, "may God give you strength, Doctor." Of course, had the situation been a lot different, him, or at least, the men of his type, would have beaten me to death. But I thanked him properly still. I'm not saying anyone who believes in the regime would kill you in the streets for protesting them, but it could be an unignited dynamite.
So I reached the hospital. And it was a fairly nice shift. Not a lot of critical patients, fortunately. So I could spend some time in the pavilion, watching my new favorite show, The Walking Dead. It's my favorite show because basically I cannot tolerate anything else because at least in The Walking Dead, the things are objectively worse for the people there than it is for the Iranians right now. That is the only thing I can tolerate. I really like the show. Daryl is my favorite character. I sure hope nothing bad happens to him. And, well, let's see how poorly this ages.
One of my patients was an 11-year-old girl coming in with a chief complaint of extreme headache in front of her head. It was nothing too serious. I asked if she's undergone any stress recently, kind of an obvious question these days, but she was a child. I asked the parents if she had any access to any of the news of the war, and they confirmed it, which sounds like very poor parenting to me.
So after making sure the hospital was stabilized, me and two of my friends went to the park near the hospital to smoke cigarettes. I had never smoked any cigarettes up until, like, two months ago. My very first cigarette was upon hearing the news, the confirmation of Khamenei being killed. And I'm really glad I waited that long because now every time I do it, I'm reminded of that night, as it was one of the best nights of my life.
Anushirvan spent more than half of his monthly salary on a VPN. Then he got online finally and was devastated. He saw some of what was being said about Iran in the wider world.
By far, the most difficult moments for me during the blackouts were times like this, where I could barely connect with the VPNs, only to see people on social media falling for the regime propaganda. And I'm not talking about Iranians. These are people living in free countries, and that is incredibly depressing to see.
I've seen charlatans actually denying the January massacre, in which dozens of thousands of people were killed, and whitewashing the Islamic Republic all the way through, just because they disagree with this war, or Trump, or the US foreign policy as a whole, outright denying the January massacre and saying there is no evidence for that, the massacre which I saw happen and the evidence I collected.
There is no excuse in that. They have zero right to do that. And for the first time ever, I truly understand why, for example, Holocaust denial is and should always be a crime, as you can't imagine the pain of seeing such privileged people denying your suffering.
Coming up, more from inside Iran, including that day President Trump said "a whole civilization will die tonight." What was that like? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, we hear from people inside Iran, people who are living through a war and an internet blackout that the UN Human Rights Office has said is, quote, "one of the longest and most severe shutdowns ever recorded globally." We're hearing what that's like from Iranians who managed to get voice memos out of the country, in spite of it being difficult and dangerous to send them.
Act Three, Neighbors, Friends, and Lovers. Iran's a big country. It had deep divisions before the war. There were massive protests against the Islamic Republic and a brutal crackdown just over a month before America and Israel attacked. And in the messages we got, responses to the war were all over the map.
All the people are happy. I'm telling you. Say thanks, President Trump. Thanks, Netanyahu. And they pray to God that Bibi and Daddy-- [LAUGHS] I mean Donald Trump-- they can-- they may help. Because many people, as a joke, and they say Daddy to him. [LAUGHS]
Vahid owns a small business. He's in his mid-40s, lives on the outskirts of a big city in northern Iran. He despises the Islamic regime, wants a secular democracy in Iran. The protests and massacres in January convinced Vahid that change will never happen without outside help.
Everyone is preparing themselves for the moment that President Trump and Bibi declare that the situation is such that people can come out. They will flood to regime to take them over. And they all expect to have a new life after this regime.
The internet is not stable. The moment you send me a message until now, it took four hours and 36 minutes arrived to me. The speed is very slow.
And you should know the Islamic Republic and their fear-- and this is not just my opinion. Everybody thinks the same thing-- is not that internet would be used against them in war. They are afraid that internet will become a tool to help protesters to get together and create an internal revolution. And that's what they are afraid of. That's why they shut down the internet.
I don't remember exactly if I told you that I have a family member, he has a bad autoimmune disorder. He was worried. We were watching Iran International by satellite. And he told me, what will come up if President Trump is going to do shutdown of electricity and all of the infrastructures? What would happen to the country?
And he was worried. He was worried about all the people like him that they have bad health issues and they need full care. I said to him, our situation is like that. We want to have freedom and going far away from this government, this IRGC. And it would be needed to pay by something.
This is the cost of freedom. And that's a shame. But I have a good feeling that this is the last second of this government.
Well, the conversations vary, but everyone talks to each other with a certain caution, meaning, in a way, they size each other up so they don't get challenged.
Omid works at a film studio in Tehran. He makes all sorts of content. He worked on a candid camera show recently. Some of the work his team has done is for state TV. He's sympathetic to the regime, including the blackouts policy. The Iranian foreign minister, Abbas Araghchi, said the internet is shut off in Iran for security reasons while the country is under attack. That idea makes sense to Omid. At work, Omid is a manager.
Out of the 24 or 25 people who work under me, one or two of them are very left leaning and opposed. For example, regarding the news of the martyrdom or death of Khamenei, who was ultimately the leader of the country-- look, I had my criticisms of his performance. But regardless, it's a war. And when you lose your leader in a war, ultimately, you're shocked, sad, and confused. But one of the guys was happy. And it was like, if he wasn't embarrassed in front of me, he would have handed out sweets.
I see the IRGC, the army, the police force, which are operating under a more or less unified command and are serving the country. They stood, fought, were killed, were martyred, were assassinated. They could have just left, but thank god they stayed. The Americans should be satisfied with Venezuela and their own oil in-- I don't know-- Saudi Arabia. They should stop their wickedness.
Regarding the internet blackout, I was forced to use a VPN. But the point is that we're in a war, and I think being connected could have perhaps caused more damage. Thankfully, we didn't have any unrest or clashes, I mean, at least not that I'm aware of. Or, I don't know, those common cyber attacks hitting those different networks, like banking network, the network of-- I don't know-- digital currency exchanges.
Most of the people around me have come to terms with the fact that right now, the conditions are wartime. And it's necessary, for example, to have certain limitations and control.
At night in Tehran and throughout a lot of the country, regime supporters have been gathering in squares to chant in support of the Islamic Republic and wave flags.
Near our office, there's a street running north to south that's uphill. I mean, it's quite uphill. I see a lady whose husband is in a wheelchair. And she's around 45, maybe 50 years old. And this lady and her husband come this way every night. They go to the Second Square of Tehranpars and chant.
And I sometimes come to the window to smoke a cigarette and I've seen them. They go by at 8:30 or a quarter to 9:00. And then they return around, like, 10:30, 11:00. And this poor woman sometimes has a hard time on the way back alone because the man is a bit heavy. And sometimes I've seen people go up an alley to help them get home.
The fact that a group of people are so patriotic and so dedicated that every night-- every night, whether it's raining, it's cold, it's hot-- they get up and come to the city squares and participate in gatherings, chant, and so on, it's really heartwarming, and it's very fascinating. I really wish you were here to see it up close.
There have been, every night, protests from the government supporters for almost one month. Whenever I'm out at almost 9:00 PM, I see them. Oh my goodness, not again.
Mahrou is in her 30s, lives outside Tehran. She works as an English tutor online. But there's not a lot of that work these days, so she's been taking on extra hours at her dad's pharmacy. She's there 'til nighttime. She sees the rallies on her way home.
The men chant repeated slogans in favor of the regime. They declare that they're ready to be martyrs of Islam and the Islamic Republic. Once I even saw a few of them wearing shrouds to prove they're ready to die for their cause. When I go to bed, I think about Reza. I immediately burst into tears. Reza is the guy I've been in love with lately who turned out to be a religious fanatic. I knew he wasn't my match, but I couldn't help but to love him.
Reza and I met at my dad's pharmacy. He's a pharmacist. We used to work different shifts. All I knew about him at first was through my brother, my brother's high opinion of him. I remember a winter evening that I went to the pharmacy to give my brother something. Being in my 30s, I'm mature enough not to believe in love at first sight. But at the very first moment I saw him, he captured my attention.
Gradually, I tried to change my work shift for two days of the week in order to meet him more. He was always well groomed and obviously picky in the way he dressed. He looked so mild-mannered, kind, always ready to help the people around him. We started texting each other. At first, it was only about work, but we gradually switched to other personal issues. At first, he was so cautious because he was our employee. But little by little, he stepped forward.
To be honest with you, I already knew that he was a religious guy, at least, more than me. But I didn't expect him to be a religious fanatic with rigid opinions about Islam and the regime. The first time that I was shocked at his perspectives was during the 12-Day War with Israel, around nine months ago. He believed that Iran should not reach an agreement or stop the war because doing so will make us lose our dignity.
I was like, what are you talking about? Iranian people are being killed. To me, dignity was an abstract concept. People's lives was something that mattered to me. Since then, I chose not to talk about politics with him. Honestly, I knew that trying to be dismissive of politics and religion was not the solution, but unfortunately, I was deeply involved with him.
Few days before the war, he left our pharmacy because he was about to establish his own. Since then, we've met a couple times. The last time we met, almost 20 days ago, he mentioned that he agreed with the idea of digital blackout for now, because in this way, the government can be in control of the enemy's propaganda against the Islamic Republic. I was like, how dare you say so? People are losing their jobs because of this blackout, and you're talking about your idea of propaganda? I think this war made me far more realistic about Reza and my love for him. This war was an accelerator. It made our relationship go downhill faster.
Act Four, Now What? Every time I hear President Trump declare what Iranians want, or what they should do, or what he thinks should come next, and every time he tosses off a threat, I want to know, what is it like for Iranians to hear that? Are they hearing that? Another thing the blackout has erased or stifled.
For instance, what was it like for Iranians on the day that happened only a few weeks ago, when President Trump posted on Truth Social about Iran, quote, "A whole civilization will die tonight, never to be brought back again. I don't want that to happen, but it probably will."
We got several voice memos about that day. I'm going to play one from the doctor, Anushirvan, who treated patients during the January massacre, then Sarah in Tehran, the woman who'd been blow-drying her hair in case US strikes knocked out Iranian power plants. Trump had set a deadline for Iran that day to open the Strait of Hormuz. The deadline was evening in the US, 3:30 in the morning in Iran.
Part of me didn't really want to take Trump seriously, but he is the president of the most powerful country in the world, so there is that. In Iran's time, it would be around 3 and 1/2 AM, if I'm not mistaken. I had charged my phone, my laptop, my portable power bank, not that they were going to last too long anyway, and had my essentials ready to go in case of emergency or if I decided to move back to my hometown, since being so high up in my current apartment, no electricity would also mean no water pump, not to mention no elevator.
I took a shower. And I think it was around 2:00 AM when I decided to leave it up to fate and sleep and wake up to either the unthinkable or to a war-torn country. And, yes, by unthinkable, I mean the ceasefire, as I had no idea what it would look like. I woke up automatically around 5:00 AM, grabbed my phone, and saw my dad's text notification that there was a ceasefire. I stared into the message a good couple minutes, stone faced, before going back to sleep.
To make all the damages caused by the war worth it, we would have to have a regime change. But now it looks like we just got the shorter stick on both ends. It brought nothing but more death and misery, not to mention it further entrenched the regime. This was one of the dumbest wars in history, to be honest.
Last night, I was awake until maybe 12:30 or so. And there's a hallway in our house that has no windows around it, no glass. So that's where we sleep at night when they bomb. We go there to take shelter. And I was trying to sleep, but I was constantly checking the internet to see what was happening, where they were saying what. And I just had a feeling that there was going to be a ceasefire.
So I couldn't sleep. But I finally did fall asleep. And then the next morning, my partner told me that there had been a ceasefire. And to be honest, my feeling when I read that news was just very, very, very full of rage, especially the things that I read. And I mean, I honestly don't know how much of it is propaganda and how much of it is reality. But the things I read, that Iran is even earning money from The Strait of Hormuz during the ceasefire. Because we, the people of Iran, know that that money earned from there is not going to be spent on us. So we're just thinking that, well, we're just going to have a richer IRGC, and they're going to commit crimes even more easily. And I'm really, really afraid for the kids who are in prison, the kids who received death sentences, because I know they're going to be persecuted terribly. Executions are going to increase.
I think we're going to have even more severe crackdowns. Probably any kind of social movement of any form, which I honestly find unlikely after the January massacres, but they'll face an even greater massacre. I feel like we're the main losers of this war, the people of Iran. Because practically nothing has changed.
One voice memo was short and to the point, from Khabat, a carpenter. He's Kurdish, an ethnic minority in Iran, living in the western part of the country.
People are really frustrated with Trump. Wasn't he supposed to keep the pressure on until the regime surrendered? Why is he going to negotiate now? He was supposed to finish them off, not talk to them.
One last person-- Arta. He runs a tech company in Isfahan. Arta's voice memos came in last. I listened after hearing all of the others. And it helped me understand something I hadn't before about where things might be headed in Iran. Arta was deeply unsettled by people around him who were furious that President Trump did not follow through on his threats, especially a promise Trump made on social media to bomb Iran back to the Stone Age.
You might not believe it, but the morning the ceasefire was announced, I actually called a friend. And he picked up the phone, saying, what is this? What a mess. Why did they just let it go? I mean, believe it or not, there is a segment of society who, in my opinion, probably lack a realistic view of what returning to the Stone Age actually entails, because maybe they don't really know what it's like to live without electricity in a fifth or sixth or 10th floor apartment.
But whether it is out of intense rage or just pure, sheer ignorance, many people prefer that we go back to the Stone Age and have our energy infrastructure be completely wiped out, as long as the Islamic regime went down with it.
So there's one group completely upset and furious, but then there's the complete opposite, the diehard loyalists ready to sacrifice their lives for the Islamic Republic. The situation is truly, it's extremely terrifying.
And for me, who's slightly in the middle-- I completely oppose the Islamic regime. But my red lines are the destruction of my country's infrastructure and the loss of my loved ones. And aside from that, if I'm being real, I'd give my own life to see the Islamic regime gone. But I do hold these two red lines.
There's another red line Arta has held for a while now. He tells this story. And this is where I felt like, oh, that is a clue, not just about the blackout and what's happening now, but something the Iranian regime seems to have been building up for years now.
Before the war, over a year ago, Arta was offered something he calls a white line. It's also called a white SIM card. White SIM cards are a way for Iranian officials and political leaders and regime-aligned journalists to bypass internet restrictions and access much more of the global internet than the general population ever has access to.
So even when there's an internet blackout or delays, if you have a white SIM card, you can get online. Arta had a contact who said they could get him a white card, a white line. But back then, Arta refused.
Many of my friends and former colleagues around me had white lines, and I knew it. But I resisted. I felt this is an undeniable right that all Iranian people should have, and I didn't want to use this special privilege. I wanted to stand alongside everyone else, living with the same hardships and struggles and VPNs and staying on this side, the side of the ordinary people.
You know what it's like? It's like using a special privilege just to have the right to eat food while the rest of your society-- your friends, your family, your siblings-- can't afford to eat meat. But because of your privilege, you do. Does that make sense? If I'm being real, I condemned a lot of my friends who used that kind of privilege. I would actually-- half jokingly, I would tell them, oh, shut up, bro, you have a white line.
We would actually talk amongst ourselves, saying, did you see that guy had a white line too, that guy who pretended to be so aligned with the people? And I was one of the proud ones. Many of my friends told me, we thought you definitely had one, but you didn't. I held my head high.
Then this war and this blackout, the longest ever. And Arta got a new offer, a new service approved by the state called Internet Pro. This would be like a white line or a white SIM card, but it would cost money, and it would give Arta a way to access the global internet. Arta is supporting his extended family. He had staff depending on him. They're an IT company. They couldn't work without the internet. So he did it. He signed up.
This was a guy who, before the war, would not even use the domestic messaging apps in the state-run intranet. He did not want to be surveilled. Now, to get Internet Pro, Arta was required to provide his national ID number, phone number, and the names and details of everyone he works with who would be using the internet. He handed all of that in.
Do I feel secure? No, not at all. Listen, I firmly believe their monitoring over me has increased significantly. I have absolutely no sense of security.
Surveillance and submission are the price of access. The blackout wasn't lifted when the ceasefire was declared, and it hasn't been lifted since. It now seems more and more possible that Iran will not return the internet back to the way it was before the war, ever.
And instead, there's a new plan-- tiered internet access, internet as a privilege granted by the state for people who support the state, or are at least willing and able to pay a state-sanctioned company for access. It turns the internet from a public place where anyone can show up and speak, listen, argue, spread conspiracy theories, find the best tweezers, to an internet that is more like an airport lounge, a silver elite, gold-plated, platinum loyalty program.
This is more and more common around the world, governments limiting internet access and sometimes going to full blackout. The whole thing has a real "coming to a country near you" vibe.
When I first listened to these voice memos from Iran, they felt to me like a rare document of a rare time, people living their lives in this temporary moment through a war and a blackout. But I think of the voice memos differently now. I think it's possible they're documenting a massive, frightening change.
That story was produced by Diane Wu.
Our program was produced today by Diane Wu and edited by Nancy Updike. Roxana Saberi and Fatemeh Jamalpour collected the voice memos for us. They're both journalists and authors. Fatemeh's book-- For the Sun After Long Nights. You can find a link to Roxana and Fatemeh's excellent reporting on what happened in January in Iran at our website.
The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Adriene Lilly, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Molly Marcello, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Lilly Sullivan, and Christopher Swetala. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, senior editor David Kestenbaum, and our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
The actors who performed the voice memos for us-- Bahar Beihaghi, Tara Grammy, Jerry Habibi, Darius Homayoun, Ava Lalezarzadeh, Abraham Makany, Arian Moayed, Navid Negahban, Babak Tafti, Pej Vahdat, Sheila Vand, and Selina Zahednia. Our wonderful casting director-- Sabrina Hyman.
Special thanks today to everyone in Iran who sent us voice memos for this story. And also special thanks to Sardar Pashai, Kaveh Dastooreh, Hossein Hafezian, Durrie Bouscaren, Ahmad Ahmadian, and Mahsa Alimardani. Shirin Jaafari, who you heard at the start of the show, is a reporter on the public radio show, The World.
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Please consider supporting the show as a This American Life Partner. You will get regular exclusive bonus episodes. You can listen ad free and more. Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.